Inserting an element into our tree,
when it has no order is relatively easy.
We'll just talker node
onto another node.
Maybe it's a leaf or
maybe it's a parent with only one child.
We only need to make sure that
we're being the two children rule.
We're given the root
at the beginning and
we'll need to keep moving down
the tree until we find an open spot.
How long will it take
to find an open spot?
The worst case is that we
travel down the longest path
until we find the farthest leaf.
In that case we'll travel
through the number of nodes
equal to the height of the tree.
But what is the height of a binary tree?
Like we did with our sorting algorithms,
let's look at some examples and
reason through it.
Here are two different trees.
We can call these perfect trees,
since every node,
except the leaves on the last level,
has two children.
It looks like this tree with
3 nodes has 2 levels, and
this one has 7 nodes and 1, 2, 3 levels.
As the tree grows bigger each new level
has the capacity to hold a number of
nodes equivalent to a power of 2.
Mull over that for a second.
Each node can have 2 children.
So each new level can have twice as
many nodes as the one before it.
Since we've gone back to
talking about powers of 2,
your mind should jump to log (n).
Does that apply here?
Let's take a look.
We see the same pattern that
we saw in binary search.
The number of levels increases
near a power of two, and now,
we have a good visualization
to understand why.
At every level, we're adding
roughly twice as many elements.
Every time we need to add a new level or
in a binary search, divider our array
another time, it's because we're giving
ourselves the space to allow for
about twice as many elements.
Remember that we're adding
a power of two at each level.
So when we count up the nodes overall
it won't be exactly a power of two.
Having three levels doesn't mean
an overall node count of eight.
But it does mean that the fourth level,
itself, will have eight elements in it.